[Musique]
bolat a été reçue lorsqu'il est entré
quasiment par effraction dans les foyers
français comme un provocateur
insupportable j'ai très mal un polar et
en même temps bâle un naïf
oui les partisans oui quelquefois il est
outrageusement partisans oui il ya eu
une espèce de jeu que de volonté
masochiste de faire venir tellement de
monde qui sait qu'un à un tiers qui
parle qui pourront pas en parler j'ai
jamais compris pourquoi
oui il ya une volonté de décider qu'on
va parler de douze sujets comme ça on va
pas chez jamais au bout de deux chacun
et polak et fait figure dans un premier
temps aux yeux du public donc puisque
d'exiger cet exhibitionniste on n'a
jamais vu ça quelqu'un qui joue sur
internet ils se montraient tout nu il
accouche les gens de ce qu'ils ont de
plus de plus vrai parce que ce qu'ils
veulent dire vraiment alors est-ce qui
traitera de la même façon un quelqu'un
qui a ses idées politiques quelqu'un qui
ne les a pas encore ça c'est pas
vraiment quelles sont ses idées
politiques m'ont dit que je pense qu'il
est en effet qu'il a plutôt une
sensibilité dix ans disons de gauche oui
si on veut employer ce mot là à mon
futur c'est pas tellement ça qui est
important je crois qu'il est il a une
sorte de ce qui plaît en lui c'est qu'il
est il a une sorte de deux positions
comme ça pour le contre les idées reçues
finalement je veux dire que vous êtes en
ceci il ne cachait pas ses opinions ne
sont pas les miennes
ce champignon d'ailleurs sont une espèce
de mélange bizarre mélange individualisé
mélange à lui peu la queue dit qu'il ya
de gauche je pense qu'il est un homme de
gauche et je dirais même qu'il est
peut-être plus fidèles à la gauche que
la gauche elle-même mafa disons que
c'est une gauche qui ne correspondent ni
au parti communiste ni au parti
socialiste actuel c'est une gauche snow
pignon gauche individualisé qui est la
sienne
toujours est il que il se présentait
comme un homme de gauche
animant des débats et ça c'est tout à
fait nous
vaud
[Musique]
alors j'ajoute une chose c'est que par
exemple en ce qui concerne les
journalistes je crois que souvent c'est
déséquilibré mais c'est déséquilibré et
ça je dois en témoigner parce que ça je
l' ai vu c'est pas tellement de sa faute
c'est qu'un certain nombre de gens
refusent de venir en particulier les
journaux du groupe hersant
moi j'ai toujours été choqué que l'on
fasse des débats où les journalistes du
figaro de france soir etc ne viennent
pas c'est vrai que c'est choquant pour
l' équilibre démocratique mais ils ne
veulent pas venir ils les invitent ils
ne veulent pas venir donc là il est
victime un peu comment dirais-je une
tactique si vous voulez mais ça on ne
peut pas leur reprocher son disque
demain ce qui est artistique de la même
manière et de et de la nature même de
l'émission c'est qu'elle a amené sur le
petit écran des gens a parlé donnant
petit écran des gens à regarder entendre
des sujets
qui habituellement n'était pas traitée
par la télévision et dans certains cas
qu'ils sont et je crois resteront comme
les grandes réussites de l'émission dans
certains cas on est allé plus loin que
d'aborder on a abouti à des moments de
vérité fort je pense à une émission qui
tenait manifestement à coeur michel
polac sur l'enfance abandonnée assister
je pense à une émission qui restera je
crois dans le souvenir de ce qu'ils ont
vu comme ce qui avait le plus
remarquable l'émission sur le casino que
qui était vraiment pour une fois très
très bien préparés ça n'est pas toujours
le cas elle croit il ya des débats sur
des sujets dont on n'avait jamais
débattu jusqu'à présent et plus en plus
encore il ya des débats auxquels sont
associés des gens à quel à qui on ne
donnait jamais la parole avant je prends
un exemple
bon il ya des débats d'abord
complètement ratée des débats
formidablement réussi mais je crois
qu'il reconnaîtrait mais parmi les
débats réussi un élu un jour sur
l'urbanisme et bien c'est le seul débat
sur l'urbanisme où j'ai vu participer
des gens qui habitaient dans les maisons
fait par les architectes et qui leur
disaient mais ces architectes tout ça
c'est bien beau mais moi j'y habite
voilà comment sait on n'avait jamais vu
ça avant alors ça c'est c'est un aspect
positif aux rudes à traiter des sujets
dont on ne prêtait jamais le pmu jamais
on avait dit des choses vraies c'est un
scandale des pmu sur le jeu sur les
sectes sur jeu que je ne sais quoi
en faisant venir des gens qu'on n'avait
jamais vu soit soit parce qu'on n'y
pensait pas soit je pense par exemple
dans un autre genre fratoni apparaissant
à l'écran on a découvert un personnage
inouïe vire on n'avait jamais vu ça
c'est du grand spectacle
toutes les télévisions occidentales donc
il n'y a pas à mon avis à mon avis c'est
non non non on a fait l'enquêté ces
démissions ou les gens tentent aussi
libre de dire ce qu'ils veulent de
raconter parfois n'importe quoi d'autre
fois de révéler des choses
extraordinaires
je crois que c'est ce qui explique le
succès je le dis mais surtout qui
explique ce rapport conflictuel que les
gens auront avec cette émission
la plupart des gens vous disent voilà
que c'est une émission au dieu si on te
laisse parler les gens on comprend rien
mais on la regarde exactement comme
quand tu es du bruit chez le voisin
quand ils jouent pas écouté on écoute
quand même bon donc il ya une sorte de
démangeaisons polak qui s'empare de la
france samedi soir
[Musique]